news now the list of shortages growing
and this time ladies are facing a lack
of feminine hygiene products we'll add
to that the so-called pink tax where an
array of items targeted to women are
more expensive than the identical ones
marketed to men basically it's just
pricier right now for us ladies heather
mills here with what you can do to
maximize your savings
walk into almost any drugstore right now
take a look down the feminine hygiene
aisle and the shelves are empty that
shortage plus a pink tax making it more
challenging and expensive to be a woman
it's a little frustrating to not be able
to find something that is really a basic
necessity for weeks store shelves have
looked like this with limited brands and
choices tampons and period products the
latest item to be hindered by the
country's struggling supply chain major
manufacturers blaming the pandemic
recalls even the war in ukraine for the
shortage but beyond the shortage there's
also a pink tax yes it is more expensive
to be a woman than it is to be a man
kristin myers is the editor in chief of
personal finance website the balance and
her company's latest study on gendered
items price discrepancies sometimes
reach 25 percent or more very well known
secret that if you want to save a little
bit of money when it comes to
shampoo or soap or and especially razors
you just hop over to the men's aisle and
you can definitely find some savings
check out the difference in these razors
men get six for eleven dollars women get
four for 20. other items also more
expensive for women like blue jeans
men's jeans were in the 20 dollar range
most of the women's pants were in the
60s even protein bars the one marketed
for women luna bars more expensive and
half the size that gendered marketing
study looked at four major national
retailers and compared 128 products hair
care body wash and lotions cost more for
ladies and anti-aging products
were sometimes as much as a hundred
percent more for women heather mills
live local now